Ми самі дуже прагнули такого місця,
де можна приходити цілодобово і творити,
займатися творчістю, займатися саморозвитком.
14 років тому ми хотіли щось змінити в цьому місті.
Це був напівзакинутий колишній дитячий садочок.
Ми його абсолютним дивом придбали
і відтоді тут було дуже багато всього,
найрізноманітнішого, в різних сферах.
Це невеличке кафе.
Воно не працює постійно як кафе,
але під якісь заходи, коли люди приходять
кіно дивитися, чи на концерт, чи ще щось.
То вони можуть тут чай, каву
чи якісь смаколики перехопити.
Нам пощастило мати класну родину, хороших батьків,
і шансів себе реалізовувати було достатньо.
Хоча, звичайно, не вистачало.
Чого нам не вистачало — ми розуміли, що багатьом
іншим цього не вистачає у значно більшій мірі, ніж нам.
За великим рахунком, все, що з'являлося
в ШELTER+ та навколо ШELTER+,
це, як ми бачили, ок, логічно, що воно було десь поруч.
Тут взагалі спочатку був клас хореографії,
а сьогодні тут просто теніс стоїть.
Настільний футбол і ще щось — приміщення,
де можна багато всього робити.
Наступна кімната —
для різних тренінгів, маленьких семінарів.
Зараз там йде дебатний клуб.
Він був у нас великий, ми робили
колись всеукраїнські дебатні змагання.
Потім ця двіжуха затихла, бо для нас важлива
не сама двіжуха, а люди, які в цьому задіяні.
Багато речей приходило із закордонного досвіду.
Коли вдалось кудись поїхати, подивитися,
що ком'юніті може взяти собі, організуватися,
і побудувати шикарний спортивний центр
із двома басейнами і тенісними кортами.
І ти починаєш розпитувати:
ну як це «ком'юніті», це хто, це держава? Та ні.
Це олігарх якийсь? Та ні.
А хто? Та ми ось взяли та побудували.
А що, так можна?
Так, дивись, так дійсно можна!
Це студія. Ми її побудували колись,
бо в нас було багато музикантів.
Ми самі колись були музикантами.
Першим ми зробили майданчик,
де музиканти у Кривому Розі просто можуть виступати.
Бо у Кривому Розі, де 600 тисяч населення, майже не було
таких неформальних майданчиків для концертів.
Тому ми в 2004 році почали як концертний майданчик.
Потім ми зрозуміли,
що для розвитку музичного ринку, бізнесу,
просто музикантів — потрібна репетиційна база.
Ми її зробили і потім логічним
було створення студії звукозапису.
Тут писались і Brunettes Shoot Blondes, і Pur:Pur.
Записали вже близько п'яти повноцінних альбомів
для різних музикантів, для різних проєктів.
Ми нічого такого феєрично нового не придумали,
не створили такого, що вау, такого ніде не буває.
Але нам трохи краще, ніж більшості інших,
вдається поєднувати людей.
Цього страшенно не вистачає
нашому улюбленому місту, як і нашій країні.
Ми не дуже можемо разом працювати.
Коли нас вже прижимає і до загибелі близько —
ми об'єднаємося і дамо відсіч завжди.
А от заради створення
об'єднуватися ми несильно вміємо.
Тому дуже хочеться цього.
Ми коли придбали цю будівлю —
тут був такий шматок землі
і ми його ніяк не могли ні для чого використовувати.
І потім у нас з'явився наш футбольний клуб.
На сьогодні це вісім футбольних команд, більше 150,
від найменших — до дорослих: діти, підлітки, молодь.
Сьогодні це такий єдиний критий
футбольний майданчик в місті, зі штучною травою,
де постійно йдуть тренування для восьми команд.
У кожної команди три тренування на тиждень, плюс ігри.
Зараз, і це дуже класно, майже до всіх
наших проєктів долучаються люди бізнесу.
І вони долучаються не просто у ролі фінансових мішків.
А вони реально свій досвід побудови команд,
досвід того, як процеси вибудовувати,
приносять у громадську діяльність.
І я можу не одну історію успіху
в цьому напрямі розказати, і мене це дуже сильно радує.
Це, взагалі, приміщення, де виставкова зала,
але вона теж використовується для якихось
невеличких тренінгів, семінарів і зустрічей, занять.
Зараз одна з команд футбольного клубу дивиться гру
і аналізує разом з тренером, як це все відбувається.
Це — дитячий клуб розвитку та розваг «Схованка».
Це така дошкільна неформальна освіта.
Тут є певна спільнота батьків дітей,
яким категорично не подобається сучасна освіта.
І які вірять, що можна зробити щось альтернативне.
У нас є ще один інклюзивний мистецький проєкт
для людей з інвалідністю — «Краще разом».
Одна дівчина, учасниця цього проєкту,
закінчила курси арт-терапії
і зараз вона пробує втілити це з дітьми
на практиці — цю арт-терапію.
Місто тотально і жахливо не пристосоване
для людей з інвалідністю.
Наші два проєкти — це спроба людей конкретно,
активно і безпосередньо долучити:
«Дружба без обмежень» — це просто до життя.
Ми формували команди: з людьми без інвалідності
і одна людина на інвалідному візку.
І завдання було дуже просте:
робіть те, що ви завжди робите.
Як ви там: на пікнік, на шашлики, в боулінг, кіно —
як ви проводите свій вільний час.
І другий проєкт «Краще разом» — це такий
мистецький проєкт, який видно на сцені.
Коли люди з синдромом Дауна, з аутизмом,
незрячі, нечуючі, на інвалідних візках —
вони разом з людьми без інвалідності творять
якийсь мистецький танцювально-театральний продукт.
«Краще разом» — він тривав тиждень, основний проєкт.
Але потім він за собою потягнув ще фактично місяці, роки,
і, віримо, десятиріччя змін.
Бо цей маркер — ставлення до людей з інвалідністю,
мабуть, взагалі найкращий і
найпотужніший маркер розвитку суспільства.
На сьогодні це вже просто як виклик:
побачити, як Кривий Ріг змінився.
Побачити, як щось в транспорті,
в інфраструктурі, в усмішках людей,
в стосунках між співгромадянами, щось змінюється.